here's a look at maiden square in kiev
ukraine we have some new developments
this morning in the ongoing threat of
war along that country's border there
are now mixed messages from russia over
whether it will invade ukraine moscow
claims that it's pulling back some of
the troops it has stationed near the
border with ukraine as other military
drills continue for the latest on this
let's bring in jackson proskow
from washington jackson so
what are we hearing from russia this
morning and what does this mean for the
likelihood of an invasion
well good morning blake you're right
russia does say that it is pulling back
some of the troops that were apparently
engaged in these military exercises
throughout the week but just a short
time ago the secretary general of nato
said they've seen no evidence of this
supposed russian troop withdrawal and
they cautioned that russia is still
planning military exercises in the
mediterranean and of course the vast
number of those troops the estimated 130
000 continue to surround ukraine on all
three sides and so the language coming
from nato allies that an invasion could
happen at any moment remains that still
stands that is still the view of nato
allies in fact a short time ago british
prime minister boris johnson spoke and
said that uk intelligence assessments
remain quite worrying in this situation
blake
okay so take what we're hearing from the
russian defense ministry with a grain of
salt we'll need to see what happens as
it pertains to troop movements at the
border what is the latest though on
diplomatic efforts now to resolve the
crisis
the fact that russia is suggesting that
it's pulling back some troops does seem
to leave that window open for further
diplomacy it would be interpreted as a
sign of de-escalation if in fact it can
be verified by the west so that is one
positive sign here uh the ukrainians
certainly hope that diplomacy remains a
possibility in this situation as does
the west but again the worrying signs
seem to trump that right now and it
almost sort of seems like a 50 50 bet as
to which way this is going to go right
now no one actually seems to know but
one thing people are really dialing in
on was this meeting yesterday between
russian president vladimir putin and his
foreign secretary sergey lavrov in which
lavrov sort of gave this highly scripted
briefing
but suggested that the window for
diplomacy has not yet closed those
avenues for de-escalation still exist
okay but as you mentioned uh nato allies
still very concerned with the build-up
of russian troops at the border it seems
like they're preparing for the worst
what's the latest there
yeah we saw that announcement from
canadian officials yesterday of
increased funding and increased lethal
aid to ukraine we're seeing similar
moves from countries around the world
with the option of loan guarantees for
example to prop up the ukrainian
government allow them to keep
functioning we should point out that
financial support is something that
ukraine has said it could really use
right now but we're also seeing those
worrying signs for example the united
states announced announced yesterday
that it is shuttering its embassy in
kiev
sending the few remaining diplomatic
staff who are there to the western part
of ukraine further away from what could
be the front lines if russia proceeds
with an invasion and of course those
dire warnings that the u.s and many nato
allies have given to their own citizens
to leave the country immediately while
it's still possible and the window for
that seems to be closing because of
course uh insurance companies no longer
want to insure aircraft in ukrainian
airspace meaning that the number of
commercial flights available continues
to dwindle by the day
something we will watch in the hours and
days to come thank you so much
jackson jackson proskow in washington
for us this morning